palestinians turned out in force to pay
tribute to the slain Palestinian
teenager they see Muhammad Ibaka dear
who was killed earlier this week as a
martyr I am verra Israeli police wanted
to give us his body last night we
refused I said I must hold a big funeral
in which the crowds can participate I
refused to hold it at night only during
the day many saw the funeral as symbolic
since it coincided with the first friday
prayers of ramadan tensions have been
running high since the teens body was
discovered at an East Jerusalem mosque
Palestinians again clashed with Israeli
police who responded with tear gas anger
has been steadily mounting across
Palestinian territory in Gaza supporters
of the radical Islamist group Hamas
demonstrated on Thursday against Israeli
airstrikes and said they were prepared
to fight back the military wing of the
group threatened to escalate rocket
attacks on targets in israel israeli
prime minister benjamin netanyahu warned
that hamas was again heading down a
dangerous path uh-huh if the firing on
our cities in the south stops so will
our response the second option is that
firing towards our residents in the
south continues our forces will then act
accordingly permits our mood on an
immature Israel has stationed tanks and
ground troops along the Gaza border
cooler heads have yet to prevail on
either side